so this is a funny little rumor that
I'll tell you straight away is not true
welcome to citre your ccii TV and Movie
Channel a
Christmas so somebody that I speak to a
fair bit um whose credibility is there
has shared this rumor with me so I will
share it with you because you never know
it might be true but it isn't that
apparently Alex curtzman has been taking
several people
at Amazon and MGM out to lunch and
trying to smoo them because he wants the
Stargate project no no no no no no no
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait he thinks he has an idea for it and
even though he didn't pitch last summer
when Amazon were asking for pitches and
I know that for a fact he apparently
according to the source is desperately
trying to get hold of a new big
franchise now now this might be related
to the fact that Alex curtzman is
wanting to move away from Star Trek is a
rumor that I've heard several times from
sources that are a little bit more
reputable and I and actually I do
believe I I
suspect there is at
least a movement
a an incline of a desire to maybe bring
Star Trek back within Paramount I've
talked to you in previous videos about
how Paramount may actually look to buy
Alex curtzman current company secret
hideout um purchase that to bring it inh
housee so that all of Star Trek is then
inhouse for if it gets to the point when
Paramount as a company is then sold
because at the end of the day Star Trek
Studios which is what it would become um
would be significantly more valuable as
an entity um rather than Star Trek as is
now because because it is shared
basically with secret hideout the IP is
owned by
Paramount but um several elements of the
shows that are produced or owned by
secret hideout so um say Paramount ended
the project with secret hideout tomorrow
the end of the contract they wouldn't
necessarily then be able to continue
making strange new rules because secret
hideout owns several elements of that IP
basically they own what they've produced
complicated I just solist explain this
to me not long ago a lawyer sorry and it
didn't make any sense
um so right now it looks like Alex
curtzman May a couple of months ago or
within the last few weeks had
conversations with several people over
at MGM and Amazon and trying to usur or
to get around or to stab in the back the
guys from the expanse at Alex curtzman
and Hawk
ostby
so what could that mean well Amazon
asked her looking at a movie and say
what you like about Alex curtzman he is
a big franchise big movie producer he
knows how to produce and how to actually
write big projects he may be looking for
an out from Star Trek
possible he may also be looking for
other big projects to do on his own or
as a from another company he can't do it
through secret hideout I should say as
well because par might have a first dibs
deal with secret hideout but basically
secret hideout can't do anything without
involving Paramount so that's part of
their current deal so it won't be
through them but curtzman does do other
projects individually basically he is a
producer separately from secret hideout
and that's how he gets around it that's
how he's getting to do now you see me
three do I think there is any chance of
this being
true no he may have had meetings with
somebody from MGM or even people from
Amazon which may have started this rumor
but I am absolutely certain for reasons
I can't tell you at the moment I'm sorry
there are certain things I know that I'm
not allow to
share but I'm absolutely certain
currently that Alex kurtzman is not
involved in any Star Trek um Stargate
project even might be involved in Star
Trek unfortunately um but he's not
involved in any Stargate project and
won't be
um again I can't tell you more than that
at the moment all I can say is that Alex
kursman won't be doing any projects with
Amazon for the
foreseeable
so what would you think though guys what
would you think if this rumor somehow
managed to be true and that Alex Kur
curtzman got his hands on Stargate would
that be your worst nightmare it would be
pretty much mine Alex curtzman
unfortunately has proven he doesn't
really care about Cannon and he is more
than willing to change whatever's come
before to fit what he thinks is ideal
for a new project look at the JJ Abrams
Star Treks JJ Abrams is blamed for those
Star Treks but Alex curtzman was
massively involved in all three he was
massively involved in them bringing
through a lot of the things that they
changed in the JJ Abrams um version um
into the first season of Discovery and
he got roundly battered for it so I
would not trust that man in the
slightest if it came to a continuation
of a new Stargate project simply because
he is incapable of actually respecting
canon in my opinion he will decide what
he thinks is best and he will run with
it he will change the way things look he
will change the way things and history
is he will basically ruin
Stargate it cannot happen but luckily
I'm 99.9% certain it's not going to so
but get into the comments and tell me
what you think Am I Wrong could this
actually be the best thing for Stargate
I guarantee you almost none of you will
agree that but hey get into the comments
if I'm wrong don't forget if you're new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification that could be my
little Christmas present if you
subscribe thank you and don't forget to
leave a comment and do big thumbs up
because that really helps us with the
algorithms okay just a very quick video
this evening as this news came in um I'm
actually watching Firefly if you over
there it's it's the train job episode
that's what that's what I'm watching at
the moment um but yeah I'm going to get
back to that now so yeah I forgot what
I've seen so
[Music]
bye